[Music]
so how does Miami compare to Jersey I'm
actually think Miami is more of like a
party town it's awesome it's more like a
vacation so Jersey has my heart you are
basically a newlywed when you went into
the show so what was that conversation
like with Chris Chris was so excited
when he heard we were coming back he was
like more excited than I was I think
yeah he's like the best support ever he
was like this is awesome because he
loved this show he loved all of us
together so he was like Supes about it
so I had no issues be around JWoww and
Nicole did you get baby fever at all oh
yeah I've had baby fever um and we do
plan on trying soon so hopefully it
hopefully soon a little meatball will be
on the way oh my god I love that season
2 has already been greenlit will you be
back and if that happens do you think
that you'll be pregnant and back I mean
I hope so because I mean some girls it
takes a while to get pregnant so I don't
want to get like you know too crazy
about it but hopefully I mean that would
be like my dream what are you the most
nervous for Chris to see play out I had
a really crazy meatball night fell all
over the place this meatball was rolling
but I tell him everything he knows all
about it the duck phone do you guys have
cell phones this time around or no cell
phones
we were cell phone free for a month but
we did have the duck phone the duck
phones back and then Angelina comes back
what is that experience like well it was
cool because I never got to live with
her I didn't really have any issues with
her so I was like whatever cool but one
thing I had to say it was definitely a
show you will say she become a permanent
cast member
well she's not here now so and then I
know of course Sammy wasn't able to come
back this season do you anticipate that
she could be back for season two I mean
I tried my hardest me and Sam are super
close so I tried my hardest to get her
to come but she's really happy and she
was nervous to come back in the house
and live like in the past with toxic
stuff so I get it but we're hoping it's
gonna be probably a different format
this next time so we're hoping maybe she
won't come in I'm just I'm gonna keep
trying what do you mean different format
um we're gonna be it's gonna be more of
our lives now but we're gonna take many
vacations so it's gonna be a little
different so I'm hoping maybe she comes
any truth to the rumors that she could
be engaged soon oh definitely she's so
in love she is so in love I hope she is
[Music]
[Applause]